من اول يوم بعد الزلزال واحنا بنسمع عن
المباني وانهيارها ولوم على المتعهدين
وطرق البناء ومنها المجمع السكني اللي لسه
كنا بنتكلم عنه واللي كان ساكن في اللاعب
ادسو هذا المجمع اسمه
مؤلف من 249 شقه وتم التسويق له على انه
قطعه من الفردوس ولكن فعليا هذه القطعه
تحولت لجحيم فالمجمع اللي قيل عنه انه
مقاوم للزلازل انهار بطريقه مؤلمه ومميته
وتحولت النظره له من الرفاهيه الى الغضب
الشعبي الكبير انه كيف مجمع سكني فاخر
وغالي وقيل انه انبنى على احدث
الطرز والتقنيات بينهار مثل كانه كرتونه
يفقدوا المئات من الناس اللي في حياتهم
بسبب الاهمال وزيكم من الشعر بيت المتعهد
اللي بين المجمع هو نفس المتعهد اللي
مسكوه في المطار بيهرب من ايام والقوا
القبض عليه مع مبالغ ماليه ضخمه واليوم
صار عدد المتعهدين اللي تم القاء الق
عليهم 131 متعهد بحسب ما اعلنت السلطات
اللي جالسه تحاسب المسؤولين خاصه وانه
اغلب الابنيه اللي انهارت في الزلزال كانت
بناء حديث يعني اقل من عشر سنوات نحن
بنتكلم وما بين القديم والحديث توجهت
انظار الناس في تركيا لجسر روما التاريخي
اللي بيعتبر من اهم واقدم الجسور في
العالم واللي مبني من 2000 سنه وما اصابوا
اي شيء في الزلزال ولليوم بيستخدموه في
مدينه اديمان جنوب شرق الاناضول والناس
اول سؤال خطر لها كيف بناء مبنى من 2000
سنه وما كان في هذا التطور بالمواد
والتقنيات ما يصيبوا اي ضرر وبناء حديث
مبني على اسس ومعايير سلامه ينهار وكانه
من الكرتون
[موسيقى]